they haven't won a game in the premier
league this season but newcastle united
now have the victory they've craved
i've always questioned whether i would
see them win anything and be late time
but now i've got belief it just means
the world football is this city simple
as a him oh oh my best day in my life
better than
better than me ben being bored to be
fair
wonderful
it's not the money we care about it's
the ambition we want something to look
forward to you know we want a team of
tries
they had that in the 90s when the goals
flowed the team sparkled and they all
loved it
but then came mike ashley who managed to
suck the joy
away from this club
finally they can say that the mike
ashley era at newcastle is over that's
why they're here but also to try and
take in what comes next huge investment
dominated by money from saudi arabia
it puts them on a footing with the
richest clubs on the planet
i wasn't even alive when we were
challenged for the champions league uh
when we last knew europa league i was
only six
and uh
i just want some of them time for myself
and
i just want the club to be something i
can support i believe in
the premier league say they are
satisfied it will be the saudi-backed
consortium controlling the club not the
kingdom of saudi arabia
and that their owners and directors
tests on transparency and a clean
financial plan have been there
for all the wonderful support
thank you commitment amanda
premier league football is the best in
the world
uh and newcastle united is the best team
in the world and we want to see it get
those trophies obviously
at top of the premier league in europe
but to get trophies it means investment
patience time
and we want everybody just to
work with us to build the club to what
it needs to be
promises have been made about who will
be involved but the saudi arabian
investment fund is overseen by crown
prince mohammed bin salman the man the
united states accused of approving the
murder of journalist jamal khashoggi
it is a real shame for the new newcastle
and for the
british
english football day
that they have now
the football club
owned by a person who responsible
the murderer of jamal
on time side they do care where the
money comes from and who owns their club
but they needed change
and the saudi-backed consortium were the
only ones offering to deliver it